I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense now how did I become the way I
am in relationships this answers at
least funny
I read Cosmo magazine so great I was
absolutely terrified that I'd be bad at
sex so when I was a teenager I had no
game
none whatsoever I did not know how to
flirt with women I actually did a Cyrano
de Bergerac
because my talent was always verbal so
that was a savage you know I'll explain
it so all of us get early wins in
something so the more energy you put
into it you get an exaggerated response
I'm gonna guess that's you with driving
that's why you and your sister did it at
the same time you got exaggerated
response you keep doing it she stops so
for whatever reason just verbally I had
to work my ass off at it and I've never
put more time and attention into
anything in my life more than verbal but
I was always getting a disproportionate
return on my energy so in my teenage
years me and my best friend fell for the
same girl but I was so terrified to
approach her and he had all the
confidence in the world but he was
terrible verbally so I actually and this
this comes from the place here on Eau de
Bergerac where this guy with a really
long nose helps this other guy woo the
woman that he loves
so I'm in the bushes telling my friend
what to say and literally at her window
wooing the girl that I and that's and
you're just using that as a figurative
example because that's what they did in
the play or that's rocks at her window
the whole night and I thought oh my god
this is so pathetic I'm actually living
out Cyrano de Bergerac that is the
example of giving your desist letting
your sister get the Easter eggs part of
the conflict but this one really came
from the place of emotional weakness I
was I was too afraid to be rejected and
so again how do I become this person I'm
willing to admit that that was emotional
weakness and my journey has been one of
toughening up yeah yeah the thing I
didn't know how to do in business the
thing that I finally had to learn in
order to get good is be tough okay so
are you a pushover
were you just sensitive we're not easily
offended tell me what used to be
tell me what it means to be to need to
work on the emotional side I was afraid
of physical confrontation which as a guy
makes you afraid of verbal confrontation
because with a girl or physically are we
talking about face-to-face sort of
conversations and hiring and firing or
well how does it play out in a civil
context it plays out in a civil context
yeah that you're afraid of confrontation
it's the easiest way of any kind
once you're afraid of confrontation
you're afraid of the truth once you're
afraid of the truth you can't be
effective no wonder I love truth because
I'm really good at confrontation that's
amazing and more powerful maybe than you
realize yeah because yeah I was so
[ __ ] afraid of it it really governed
everything in my life and so my life was
about overcoming that yeah yeah that was
one of the biggest things I've had to
learn
you